bonjour et bienvenue au forum radio judo
vous êtes l'invité François Bayrou
bonjour bonjour alors la détermination
d'Emmanuel Macron à tenir sur la réforme
des retraites malgré une contestation
qui ne faiblit pas augurtel d'un climat
serein dans le pays radicalisation
d'opposition à la réforme violence dans
les manifestations bras de fer avec les
syndicats incompréhension de l'opinion
le quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron est-il
définitivement entravé comment en tout
cas peut-il rebondir pour sortir de
l'impasse politique mais alors pour
commencer François Bayrou que vous
inspire ce samedi de violence de
violence extrême hier à Sainte-Souline
entre force de l'ordre et manifestants
venus pour en découdre armée d'explosifs
de grenades artisanale de cocktail
Molotov de H ou de couteau
vous voyez bien il y a un mouvement de
de déstabilisation et de destruction de
la part de que comme digérer le dammana
de l'extrême gauche de déstabilisation
et de destruction c'est un mouvement
réfléchi concerté
sans aucun lien avec la réalité parce
que là on s'attaque à des retenues d'eau
dans un temps et dans des régions où la
sécheresse menace depuis longtemps et
pour lutter contre la sécheresse et bien
on fait des bassins c'est ce que réclame
les agriculteurs du coin c'est ce que
réclame les agriculteurs du coin c'est
ce que soutiennent les écologistes du
département voisin dont principe
bateau qui a retiré sa signature et à
cette demande tous
disent mais enfin si vous voulez qu'on
échappe à la désertification on a besoin
d'eau
si vous voulez que ce soit de l'eau qui
ne
handicape pas le milieu qui ne qui ne
fasse pas baisser les nappes phréatiques
alors faut prendre pendant l'hiver quand
il y en a beaucoup et puis la relâcher
dans le milieu
pendant l'été quand on en a besoin
l'histoire de l'humanité depuis
trois ou quatre mille ans et notamment
depuis l'Égypte ancienne l'histoire de
la civilisation c'est l'histoire de la
maîtrise de l'eau de la régulation de
l'eau et l'histoire des conflits et si
on réfléchissait un quart de seconde
si on veut diminuer le CO2 dans
l'atmosphère qui est le principal gaz à
effet de serre un agent du réchauffement
lié à l'activité humaine
qu'est-ce qui prélève le CO2 qu'est-ce
qu'il le fixe c'est la végétation et si
vous n'avez pas d'eau vous n'avez pas de
végétation y compris
on y vient après si vous voulez et donc
le 7 ce cet immense besoin
et cette logique imparable qui consiste
à fixer le CO2 de l'atmosphère par
l'agriculture et bien c'est quelque
chose de non seulement de logique mais
de mais de nécessaire y compris
mais le Maïs est une plante formidable
est une plante
magique probablement celle qui fixe le
plus de CO2 dans l'atmosphère mais il
est vrai que le maïs doit s'adapter lui
aussi les plantes la culture et s'il est
mieux de faire du sorgho parce que le
sorgho a moins besoin d'eau que le maïs
il y a des régions dans lesquelles on
peut faire du maïs la mienne en vous dit
tout ça ça mérite pas ce qui s'est passé
hier
le le plan le plan est un plan de
destruction mais alors de la part de qui
de la part de tous ceux qui sont dans
une dans une idéologie
nihiliste on va dire de de
d'incendie de tout ce que nous avons
construit et de prise de contrôle de la
société par la violence y compris y
compris François Bayrou il les élus il y
avait une dizaine d'élus ELV donc dans
la secrétaire nationale de d'Europe
Écologie Les Verts madame chandelier
dont une dizaine de députés ELV et
insoumis est-ce que eux m'attendent de
destruction en tout cas il accepte il le
connaisse très très bien et il accepte
parce qu'ils imaginent que la lutte
violente peut permettre de faire
triompher des idées de la lutte
idéologie d'une utilisation c'est ça de
ce qui pense donc qu'il l'accepte et
c'est probablement y a-t-il dans ces
mouvements des gens de bonne foi
j'en connais mais je dis que que nous
avons là une menace c'est une menace de
tentative d'imposer par la violence une
idéologie
qui dominerait désormais la société
Gérald Darmanin avait dit à 5 mois quand
il s'est passé la même chose au même
endroit il avait parlé de déco
terrorisme
si vous voulez bien jouer
mes propres mots
c'est une tentative de prise de contrôle
et d'imposer une idéologie par la
violence par la violence alors dermana
parle de violence criminelle Isabelle
alors l'autre côté côté de
des opposants et des des soutiens aux
manifestants d'hier vous avez
Sandrine segol député ELV de Strasbourg
qui a considéré que le principal
responsable de la violence était le
ministre de l'Intérieur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon est-elle encore plus
loin un tweet de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
assez de violence policière à
Sainte-Souline assez sans les bras même
sans se cirque il ne se passerait
absolument rien d'autre qu'une marche
dans les champs
oui le la tentative de renvoyer sur ceux
qui ont la responsabilité
de l'ordre républicain de la lutte
contre la violence de
garantir que chez nous personne
n'imposera
brutalement une vision ou une idéologie
c'est c'est le peuple quand il vote qui
décide c'est pas la rue qui décide ce
n'est pas la rue qui décide c'est le
peuple des citoyens qui décident et donc
cette tentative de de choisir la
brutalité la violence et la destruction
pour imposer sa propre idéologie
à tout un pays qui Dieu sait est
infiniment éloigné de cette question le
si vous croyez que parmi les Français
qui travaillent qui sont à la retraite
ou qui ont du souci pour leur famille la
question des retenues d'eau à Sainte
Soline est une question qui leur importe
vous trompez et ils savent que si on
veut sauver l'agriculture il faut au
minimum qu'on lui permette c'est ce
qu'on veut maîtriser l'eau c'est ce
qu'on veut dire peau je crois pas que la
peau ce sujet
faut-il dissoudre des bravesmes brigades
de répression de l'action violente
motorisée comme le réclame depuis depuis
jeudi d'ailleurs et cette manifestation
vivante que contre la réforme des
retraites et les filles et la nups
moi je trouve que le travail de la
police est de cette police ou de ces
unités de maintien de l'ordre ce travail
est remarquable parce que vous avez vu
il y a pas eu de victimes pour l'instant
jamais en dépit des violences des
dizaines de blessés en dépit des
violences
voilà non et puis faut voir ce qu'on
appelle blesser et les forces de l'ordre
aussi sont victimes je trouve que le
travail que fait
que font les policiers en région
parisienne et en province et les
gendarmes est un travail remarquable
parce que ils ont constamment pour
objectif de ne pas avoir de dérapage or
c'est des dérapages étant donné le
climat de tension d'injures de coût qui
comme
on sait peuvent parfaitement arriver et
c'est donc un travail remarquable
encore faut-il qu'il y ait pas de
débordement
il peut y avoir aussi des débordements
du côté de ceux qui canon assez de se
faire caillasser les policiers on a
entendu ce dialogue entre guillemets
entre ces policiers de la bravème et
puis des manifestants et vous a choqué
il y a des dérables il peut y avoir des
dérapages et je sais que le préfet de
police en particulier qui fait un
travail superbe
sérieux et attentif aux risques
ce travail là maîtrise aussi les
dérapages luttes contre les dérapages
mais
vous savez ces policiers là ils ont des
familles ils ont des enfants
ils ont
leur souci et leur situation est pas
mirobolante même si elle a été améliorée
c'est très bien qu'elle le soit
il y a des hommes derrière les casques
il y a des familles derrière les casques
et il y a des familles il y a des hommes
et des femmes
il y a des gens courageux et qui sont
blessés d'être constamment jetés à la
vindique populaire alors ceux qui en a
assez aussi d'être jeté constamment la
veille populaire ce sont aussi les élus
donc une violence vous allez
manifestations et qu'entre les élus qui
atteint des niveaux jamais atteints
justement la présence du groupe
Renaissance à l'Assemblée Aurore Berger
a reçu une lettre avec des menaces de
mort contre son bébé de 4 mois et je me
suis exprimé hier sur ce sujet ignoble
sur cette sur ces events cet événements
ignables en arrivait en France
en 2023
à ce que des
des tarés je peux pas dire autre chose
les cerveaux malades des gens qui ont
perdu le sens commun et et le sens de ce
qu'ils sont eux-mêmes
envoie une lettre à une jeune femme
députée qui vient d'avoir un bébé pour
menacer son bébé et dire au moins on
pourrait l'attraper parce qu'il pourra
passer s'échapper c'est ça qui est écrit
je trouve que ça mérite
qu'on se mobilise tous en disant on va
pas laisser continuer cette dérive et
c'est des rapaces
c'est une barbarie c'est une barbarie
pas encore accomplie mais c'est une
barbarie en volonté en projet et qui un
jour peut se transformer en Barbarie en
acte et cette j'espère qu'on pourra
trouver des éléments pour savoir qui
quand pourquoi et que tous ensemble tous
ensemble toutes opinions confondues on
sera impitoyable avec ce genre de ce
genre de négation de tout ce que nous
sommes de négation de de tous ces
siècles
qui ont essayé de construire une
civilisation on respecte les gens
où on essaie de les comprendre et où on
se sert de sa tête moins autant que des
éruptions qu'on ressent en soi-même
l'éruption qu'on reçoit dans la rue
violence à Sainte-Soline violence
saccage jeudi dans le cadre de la des
manifestations contre contre la réforme
des retraites à Paris en Provence est-ce
que nous sommes arrivés à un moment de
bascule François Bayrou et est-ce que ça
est-ce que ce qui se passe ne donne pas
une image désastreuse de la France oui
c'est une image désastreuse de la France
est une je vais vous dire c'est une
image désastreuse de l'humanité parce
que franchement
parce que quelqu'un qui va écrire une
lettre de menace contre la vie d'un bébé
simplement parce que sa maman est
députée celui-là
il a affranchi une borne et ce qui se
passe dans les rues alors
qu'il y ait des protestations à mon sens
elles ne sont pas fondées
comme on va parler de la réforme elles
ne sont pas fondées ce qui est fondé au
contraire c'est la prise de conscience
que on doit absolument équilibrer notre
système de retraite si on veut qu'il
dure mais
il y a
des militants des citoyens qui ne sont
pas de cet avis et il est normal qu'il
puisse exprimer ses scènes démocratie
mais que cette expression elle soit en
réalité
dévoyé par une volonté de destruction du
lien social et des règles de la société
dans lesquelles nous sommes ça c'est
condamnable et ça doit être condamné par
tout le monde au passage au passage
François baillon l'annulation la visite
du roi Charles III en France qui devait
arriver donc ce dimanche
est-ce que c'est pas une humiliation à
la fois pour la France et pour Emmanuel
Macron
je n'emploie pas ce registre de mots
vous voyez bien les commentaires qui
aurais-tu s'il avait été là c'était le
roi de France reçoit le roi d'Angleterre
pendant que le peuple de manifeste dans
les rues et dans la dans de la vaisselle
en or aurait-il dit on ne on humilie le
peuple en lui montrant les privilèges de
ceux qui depuis siècle l'exploite c'est
ça qu'on aurait voulu dire mais
il y a une chose que vous avez essayé
souvent de me faire dire c'est les
conversations que j'avais le président
de la République comme vous savez vous
n'arriverez pas
essayer
c'est une bonne chose non je dis pas que
c'est une bonne chose j'aurais vraiment
préféré que ça ne soit pas le cas qu'on
en soit pas dans cette situation là mais
il y a des moments de tension tous les
pays en connaissent euh
le Royaume-Uni autant que les autres
même en ce moment et donc je suis sûr
que
ça sera compris accepté en tout cas et
que on pourra recevoir le roi Charles
lorsqu'il viendra la prochaine fois si
ça se passe bien d'ici là on a une part
du début j'étais est-ce que c'est pas le
49-3 qui a mis le feu au pays
qui est en train de mettre le feu au
pays la situation était il y a eu plein
de je veux pas dire d'erreurs mais ouais
mais vous avez prononcé le mot
dans le cadre de
insuffisances où on n'a pas tout à fait
rempli pas tout à fait c'est une litote
les
les objectifs qu'on aurait dû remplir
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui a manqué et
le président de la République l'a dit
mais on aurait dû le faire avant
ce qui a manqué c'est qu'on explique
simplement la situation à chacun des
citoyens français que chacun et puis se
faire une idée
je porte une idée de la démocratie
depuis longtemps qui est que les
citoyens peuvent être partis prenantes
de la décision politique
les citoyens sont co-responsables avec
les pouvoirs de toute nature pouvoir
exécutif pouvoir législatif partie
syndicale mais les citoyens en tant que
tel sont co-responsables encore faut-il
qu'on leur explique on leur a pas
expliqué en tout cas c'est pas seulement
qu'on
n'a pas expliqué on s'est laissé égarer
par une présentation à mes yeux
fallacieuse ou trop optimiste ou ou
on voit chose en rose de la situation
actuelle
[Musique]
au fond le régime de retraite
actuellement était équilibré ceci est un
mensonge
généralisé non seulement ça n'est pas
équilibré c'est en déficit ça serait en
déficit tous les ans si l'État ne venait
pas compléter les ressources du régime
de retraite
en versant tous les ans aux caisses de
retraite ou à sa propre caisse de
retraite des dizaines de milliards vous
avez dit 30 milliards entre 30 et 40
j'ai dit 30 pour choisir un chiffre
indiscutable qui n'a d'ailleurs je vous
ferai remarquer était discuté par
personne bon
alors cet argent si on l'avait s'il
était dans le budget de l'État
tous les ans on pourrait décider après
tout c'est une utilisation comme une
autre on pourrait dire on va soutenir
les pensionnés et on va
assumer payer ce qui manque au budget
des caisses ça veut dire dans 10 ans
3300 milliards et la vérité 300
milliards au moins si c'est pas 46
[Musique]
et quand on emprunte qu'est-ce qu'on
fait on met sur le dos des générations
qui viennent le remboursement de des
sommes empruntées
3000 milliards et ça coûte 50 milliards
de de de frais de d'intérêt par an et
dans cette dette les apports de l'aide
du budget de l'État aux caisses de
retraite c'est une part non négligeable
ou importante de cette dette est-ce
qu'on peut continuer comme ça surtout
quand on sait que ce déficit de au moins
30 milliards tous les ans il va croître
dans les dans les années qui viennent
pour des raisons démographiques
vous trouvez dans une situation où il y
avait beaucoup de retraités pour payer
beaucoup d'actifs pour payer les
requêtes et aujourd'hui
à dire cette réforme des retraites elle
est elle était elle est indispensable et
ça c'est elle est vitale
un pays qui accepterait de mettre la
charge des pensions qui accepteraient
durablement ce qu'on fait depuis des
décennies qui accepterait durablement de
mettre la charge des pensions sur le dos
des futurs actifs ce pays-là a choisi
une voie immorale et je ne et je ne
pense pas que qui que ce soit de
conscience puis soutenir le contraire
c'est la raison pour laquelle si on
avait mis à disposition de tous les
citoyens les éléments que je vous donne
là mais on intergit versé parce que on
ne voulait pas s'opposer à cette
présentation qui était celle de
l'institution qu'on avait construite
pour surveiller soi-disant les choses on
va préciser des choses quand même des
Macron il y a les événements il y a
Olivier dussobe la plupart des
dirigeants la majorité ceux qui se sont
trompés non c'est oui tout le monde
s'est trompé complètement majorité et
opposition y compris présentement public
non le président de la République vous
l'avez entendu lui au moins a affronter
cette question lui au moins 10 les mots
sur la situation du pays et c'est assez
courageux parce qu'il y a pas grand
monde qui disent les mots nous en
parlerai
un public moi j'ai pas peur de la
popularité dans quatre ans je serai plus
candidat oui mais forcément c'est
notre règle constitutionnelle alors
avançons un peu tout le monde
à quelques rares exceptions près puisque
le puisque le rapport du plan
a dit les choses de manière je crois
indubitable précision précise vous êtes
au commissaire européen tout le monde a
complément
saisis la présentation de la situation
cette présentation on va dire pour le
moins optimiste qui est en réalité une
manière d'égarer le jugement
tout le monde a saisi cette présentation
l'opposition pour dire il n'y a pas
besoin de réforme des retraites et
le pouvoir pour dire au fond on va
arriver à rééquilibrer d'ici 10 ans ça
sera parfaite ça sera à l'équilibre ce
qui ce qui est comme vous le voyez très
largement discutable et sera
nécessairement discuté dans la vie des
précisions par rapport à l'actu
l'actualité Laurent Berger il demande il
vous demande il demande au Président
public de mettre une pause sur la
réforme de retraite pour apaiser le
climat social est-ce qu'il faut
l'entendre est-ce qu'il faut l'écouter
et puis éventuellement de quelle manière
non mais le
tout le monde fait semblant d'ignorer le
le cheminement institutionnel donc le
texte
le Conseil constitutionnel a été adopté
il est maintenant devant le Conseil
constitutionnel saisi par une partie des
oppositions saisit par le gouvernement
pour que le Conseil constitutionnel le
disent est-ce que c'est correct ou pas
par rapport à nos règles
institutionnelles et il a je crois qu'il
reste trois semaines encore d'ici au 20
avril il a un mois pour se tuer pour que
le Conseil constitutionnel se prononce
sur ces sujets les sujets plus vite liés
aux réforme des retraites parce que une
partie de l'opposition à proposer
connaît un référendum d'initiative
partagée c'est-à-dire un référendum qui
serait déclenché à la fois par les
parlementaires et par 4 millions de
signatures et donc sur tous ces thèmes
le Conseil constitutionnel va se
prononcer alors je vous dis est-ce que
vous souhaitez qu'il aille plus vite non
mais l'urgence n'a pas été demandé
personne ne peut l'urgence n'a pas été
demandé parce qu'elle n'aurait pas été
acceptée le Conseil constitutionnel
aurait dit non mais vous allez pas me
demander l'urgence sur quelque chose qui
traîne depuis des décennies
[Musique]
vous avez voté un texte et bien on va
examiner
constitutionnellement et heureusement il
n'y a pas de moyen de pression et une
dépression ne serait pas acceptée sur le
Conseil constitutionnel vous voyez c'est
très ce que nous avons entre les mains
c'est très précieux c'est un joyau on
croit que c'est quelque chose de banal
d'ordinaire l'État de droit qu'est-ce
qu'il protège il protège les droits des
plus faibles alors et notamment les
droits des oppositions les droits des
minorités les droits de 7 minorités
ultime
qui est le citoyen qui a tout seul une
conviction et qui veut pouvoir à la fois
l'exprimer et la faire entendre et
l'avoir respecté Laurent Berger pour qui
je crois vous avez beaucoup de respect
il a donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut lui
répondre mettre une pause ou pas sur la
réforme des retraites Emmanuel Macron
dit je suis ouvert je suis disponible
pour recevoir la terre syndicale mais
après la du Conseil constitutionnel donc
ça nous fait attendre encore un mois
trois semaines
avec éventuellement des violences dans
les rues et ainsi de suite il faut
renouer non seulement le dialogue mais
la correspondabilité que nous tous
citoyens français nous avons devant
l'évolution de la situation la
correspondabilité ça comprend pour moi
le pouvoir naturellement
les majorités les mouvements de la
majorité les mouvements de l'opposition
les syndicats et même les citoyens on
peut le faire avant avant la décision du
Conseil constitutionnel ou non mais
laissez chacun d'entre eux ma conviction
et qui se parle quand même donc parce
que l'échange
les échanges sont
nombreux nourris et je crois respectueux
après il y a des il y a des moments de
tension il y a des moments
d'affrontement on souhaite qu'il y en
ait pas mais cette vision iréniste comme
pour dire une vision où on croit que
tout est paisible cette vision iréniste
n'est pas la plus lucide ou la plus
objective de temps d'autant moins
lucides quand on entend par exemple
Jean-Luc Mélenchon il disait le 11 mars
nous allons trouver une porte de sortie
par la force et depuis il encouragé les
populations spontanées dans le pays ils
jouent avec le feu il met de l'huile sur
le feu c'est un dirigeant séditieux pour
reprendre les termes de d'Emmanuel
Macron à factieux non je pense qu'il a
une stratégie et cette stratégie c'est
une stratégie de
déstabilisation de notre société
par la multiplication des affrontements
et pour arriver à la multiplication pour
arriver à prendre le pouvoir ou oui
la société essayons de pas prendre de
mots excessifs
c'est une stratégie pour obliger
ou pour obtenir la prise de contrôle de
la société par un mouvement idéologique
qui qui imposerait sa vue aux autres et
c'est ce qu'on appelle révolution
révolution ou dictature c'est la raison
pour laquelle j'ai toujours été du côté
des réformistes ce qui disent prenons
notre monde comme il est voyons que
c'est le plus généreux qui existe sur la
planète
avec des défauts sans doute avec des
insuffisances je le crois mais en tout
cas on peut pas trouver de pays dans
lequel
l'éducation est gratuite la santé est
gratuite le chômage est garanti à tout
le monde la retraite est garantie à tout
le monde et si vous faites le tour de
l'Europe et le tour du monde on en
parlait dans le couloir à l'instant
puisque vous rentrez des États-Unis
une société qui soit aussi attentive en
fait à ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
aussi généreuse on peut dire aussi
généreuse aussi attentive est-ce que
c'est bien fait non la preuve parce
qu'il y a cette incroyable
mise à disposition de ressources mais
les résultats notamment des services
publics de l'éducation peut-être de la
santé sont pas se qu'on souhaiterait
faute d'erreur qui ont été commises
parfois il y a des décennies le l'erreur
du numérique clausus tel qu'il a été
mise en place et maternité il y a des
décennies et c'est criminels par rapport
à l'équilibre du système de santé en
France nous avions le système de santé
le plus performant et le plus respecté
de la planète bon et puis on se et bien
la règle ou la le devoir est simple tout
cela nous avons à le reconstruire et
nous ne le reconstruirons pas dans le
chaos
par rapport à tous ceux qui voudraient
obtenir le chaos nous ne le
reconstruirons que si nous savons
légitimer l'ordre qui nous permet
d'avancer et de vivre ensemble vous
dites nous le reconstruirons pas dans le
chaos il faut attendre que le Conseil
constitutionnel donne son avis d'ici
trois semaines
d'ici là il va se passer des choses il y
aura sans doute il y aura peut-être
d'autres manifestations de l'un de celle
du de mardi la dixième journée de
mobilisation est-ce que vous craignez
des troubles de la violence est-ce que
vous adressez un message au syndicats à
leur envergés ce que vous leur dites il
faut peut-être savoir arrêter un
mouvement non je veux dire quelque chose
de que je ressens profondément les
syndicats ont été responsables
plus que responsable ils ont été garant
de la paix civile et de au fond du
respect que cette paix civile et ses
règles deviennent en commun imposent à
tous les citoyens ils ont pu manifester
beaucoup avec beaucoup de monde
et puis en même temps c'est pas eux qui
ont accepté les incidents ils ont tout
fait pour essayer d'aller à l'encontre
de ces de ces minorités qu'il voit très
bien
s'il y a quelqu'un en France qui
identifie parfaitement le plan de ces
minorités la stratégie de
déstabilisation et de destruction
qu'elles mettent en oeuvre c'est bien
les syndicats parce que il lutte sur le
front eux sont sur le front et donc
c'est pour ça qu'ils disent aussi faut
pas politiser ce mouvement oui donc je
suis
moi je suis admiratif de ce qu'ils ont
fait bon et maintenant et c'était pas
garanti il y a encore quelques quelques
semaines
donc je trouve ça
d'une certaine manière très
encourageante il faut que quelque chose
se renoue qu'on appelle démocratie
sociale il n'y a pas que la démocratie
politique il y a la démocratie des
syndicats des organisations
professionnelles des entreprises au fond
de la démocratie autour de la personne
au travail et comment ça se passe et
bien ça se passe par le dial je suis sûr
que le Président de la République a son
rôle a joué dans la redéfinition de ce
dialogue et d'autres de quelle manière
et quand et d'autres et je pense que
même le plan avec la toute petite équipe
qui est l'assiette à son rôle donc votre
équipe mais mais quand est-ce qu'il faut
attendre la vie du Conseil
constitutionnel est-ce qu'on peut
l'attendre ou est-ce qu'il faut
accélérer les choses et ce qu'il faut
que ça se passe maintenant pour éviter
que la France tombe dans le cas qui a
plus de dialogue du tout je crois que
vous vous trompez
je pense il y a des échanges je pense
que tout le monde voit la difficulté de
la situation car elle est difficile je
pense que tout le monde se rend compte
que
on est en situation de risque et qu'il
faut réduire le risque de porte pour la
base il peut y avoir des violences il
peut y avoir des débordements il peut y
avoir des mouvements incontrôlés
bien sûr le beaucoup de gens sont
choqués aussi de cette violence à ce
qu'il voit sur leurs écrans des des feux
allumés partout d'une société dans le
fait que partout ou dans beaucoup
d'arrondissements de Paris ne soit plus
ramassé une ville livrée à la à
l'invasion des déchets à des marées de
déchets auquel au passage les
manifestants mettent le feu vous croyez
que tout le monde ne voit pas la
différence
heureusement pour pas ce genre de et je
rends hommage au passage à tous ceux qui
font vivre le service public pendant ce
temps et qui sont pas tous
persuadés de la justesse des mouvements
en question mais vous leur dites il faut
arrêter non je donne pas d'injonction
d'accord je
comment bien je vais vous dire les
choses
l'avenir nous le construirons ensemble
alors essayons de ne pas être les uns en
situation de donner des des jugements
péremptoirs et des injonctions pour
aller dans le sens qu'il souhaite je
pense que c'est mieux de de scruter les
progrès possibles et de nommer les
remarquables
maîtrisent la remarquable maîtrise par
exemple des organisateurs des
manifestations alors si je vous entends
vous pensez que Emmanuel Macron a raison
de ne pas remettre en cause la réforme
des retraités qui va remettre en cause
une réforme qui a demandé autant de
centaines d'heures de débats
oui bon je pense quand même temps ils
sont respectueux du fonctionnement de la
démocratie politique
c'est ce que nous allons voir tous
ensemble alors le bilan politique de
cette séquence il est quand même assez
désastreux pour la majorité à laquelle
vous apportez
les choses code de popularité il faut
s'en tenir il faut regarder ce qui se
passe du côté des sondages d'Emmanuel
Macron et des habits de bornes en berne
puis à ce sondage publié c'était ce
matin dans le Journal du Dimanche qui
montre que les attentions de vote au
législatives en faveur de la majorité
sont en chute libre moi cinq points le
RN en hausse 5 points la nuit pesos d'un
petit point et les républicains en
baisse d'un point et tout ça au bout
d'un an est-ce que c'est pas inquiétant
François Bayrou
c'est pas une situation confortable mais
nous ne sommes pas en période électorale
non mais certains
si vous regardez ce qui s'est passé dans
les années et les décennies précédentes
mille fois on a eu on a eu ce genre de
ce genre de choses
une situation qui exige des décisions
difficiles
une mise en cause très nombreuse des
maladresses peut-être des insuffisances
à coup sûr bon simplement il faut
maintenant passer le cap alors et quand
le cap sera passé la question sera de
reconstruire parce que je parlais de la
démocratie sociale à l'instant est-ce
qu'elle marche bien
je crois pas
il s'agit pas seulement de reconstruire
quelque chose qui marcherait qui aurait
marché bien avant ça fait combien de
temps que ça parce que ça fait très
longtemps ça fait des décennies que que
on n'a pas su trouver la place de chacun
le rôle de chacun et l'enrichir pour
pour avoir une société qui accepte de
regarder en face ces difficultés et de
construire ensemble des réponses
ensemble des réponses et on se dit on se
demande je vous demande est-ce que
le projet de loi immigration par exemple
elle a été reportée est-ce que c'est pas
le signe que le quinquennat d'Emmanuel
Macron est totalement peut-être
définitivement en travers ne prenez pas
mal ce que je vais dire c'est du blabla
de journaliste pas seulement parce que
vous avez très bien que c'était aussi
par un certain nombre de dirigeants de
majorité
[Musique]
il y a toujours des armes c'est aussi du
blabla il y a toujours des il y a
toujours des âmes flageolantes
quand les tempêtes viennent
il y a beaucoup de gens qui qui
préféreraient gagner le port et se
mettre à l'abri
décide pas tout seul est-ce qu'il est
pas isolé est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez non je je c'est pas mon
sentiment et dans la réforme des
retraites ça n'a pas été le cas c'est le
gouvernement qui a mené les négociations
qui a élaboré le texte vous savez bien
ce que je pense je pense que le texte
précédent était meilleur que celui-là
celui que non une retraite enfin de
texte de la retraite
c'était c'était prise en compte plus
globale et elle permettait que le choix
des citoyens un peu à la carte s'exerce
sur la décision des retraites peut-être
on y reviendra un jour je ne crois pas
je ne crois pas du tout qu'on soit au
terme de la réflexion sur les retraites
Michel Rocard disait vous savez bien il
y a de quoi faire tomber 10
gouvernements
on y est presque mais on n'est pas tout
tout à fait donc non pour la raison que
je vous indiquais le dés libre
budgétaire des retraites il est toujours
là et donc nous aurons forcément la
nécessité si nous ne voulons pas que la
dette simplement
ce que j'ai essayé de faire entendre je
suis pas arrivé c'est que il n'y a pas
que la longement de la durée du travail
il y a d'autres contributions qui
peuvent venir
un peu des entreprises un peu de la
fiscalité sur ceux qui ont la chance de
bénéficier de la de la situation de
trouver des super trophiques comme on
dit ou en tout cas des avantages
considérables intervention télévisée il
en a parlé c'était un moment et c'était
un moment très important de vous
préciser les choses puisque c'est la
première fois que le Président de la
République abordait ce sujet
qui est pour moi un sujet très important
parce que il n'y aura pas de réforme
celle-ci comme d'autres s'il y en a qui
viennent il y aura pas de réforme sans
sentiment de justice et on ne peut pas
demander à une seule catégorie de la
population c'est-à-dire les actifs les
salariés de faire seul
l'effort nécessaire ce que j'ai proposé
dans dans la dans l'analyse du plan que
vous indiquez c'est qui est un mix de
contribution et ça peut encore se faire
dans le cadre des négociations qui ont
lieu après le jour où nous aurons
l'obligation d'affronter la situation de
notre pays notamment du point de vue de
la dette alors faudra faire preuve
d'imagination sur ces sujets alors
concrètement comment on peut sortir
comment Emmanuel Macron peut sortir du
tel crise comment peut-il rebondir pour
sortir de l'impasse politique comment
par un référendum vous allez dire encore
c'est du blabla de journaliste par un
remaniement par une dissolution
de Bor
je pense qu'il faut éviter la politique
par à coup
c'est-à-dire tout d'un coup
il y a quelque chose qui va mal alors on
se met à tout détruire de ce qu'on a
fait et à vouloir
imposer des démarches nouvelles et qu'on
abandonnera encore dans quelques mois
pas du tout comme ça qu'il faut
patiemment reconstruire les relations
démocratiques et les relations sociales
en France il faut patiemment
identifier les sujets sur lesquels nos
compatriotes au travail par exemple dans
l'entreprise par exemple
face à la santé par exemple face à
l'école
s'il y avait un sujet
sur lequel on a le devoir de s'investir
et j'ai passé une partie de ma vie à
réfléchir à ce sujet c'est le sujet de
l'école donc ça c'est des sujets de
l'environnement également et donc ça
c'est urgent et est-ce que c'est pas
urgent c'est
vital pour notre société est-ce que
Elisabeth borne est en mesure de
s'occuper de ces sujets elle est au
travail et le président de la République
a répété quel était son quel était son
soutien je pense qu'il y aura forcément
des reconfigurations de quelle manière à
Matignon non pour l'ensemble de
l'exécutif
je ne suis pas président de la
République et je m'exprime pas en son
nom c'est le président de la République
qui prend ce genre de décision et elles
sont suffisamment importantes pour qu'on
essaie de pas utiliser les mots à la
légère mais d'ici quelques semaines vous
pensez qu'il va avoir un
un changement profond au sens que je
pense qu'on a besoin le pays a besoin de
reconfiguration pour l'instant
aujourd'hui configuration pour l'instant
aujourd'hui les choses sont un peu
gelées un peu
bon dans une période d'expectative mais
ça veut dire quoi et le président de la
République prendra j'en suis sûr les
initiatives nécessaires c'est son boulot
c'est sa mission et c'est son goût en
plus le monde prête une phrase Elisabeth
band je suis entouré de milice débiles
vous croyez aussi non encore une fois
vous devrez savoir comment les journaux
s'écrivent vous devriez être en France
Monsieur Aziza le l'expert patenté
de la manière dont les journaux
s'écrivent et dans les citations se font
et donc non je crois pas du tout
je crois pas du tout qu'Elizabeth borne
et dit ça et je vous demandais est-ce
que vous le croyez vous
que il y a beaucoup de ministres débiles
non je prête pas ce genre de
enfin j'utilise pas ce genre de jugement
alors vous avez participé hier vous avez
assisté en tout cas hier au Congrès
d'horizon
est-ce qu'on crée la loyauté de loi
Philippe envers la majorité envers
Emmanuel Macron oui et donc il est en
piste pour 2027
2027 contrairement à ce que vous croyez
c'est loin c'est très loin et on devrait
être vacciné les uns et les autres sur
au moins un sujet c'est le temps qui
passe et le laisser du temps au temps
c'est ça c'est pas seulement qu'il faut
laisser du temps au temps il faut savoir
que le temps change beaucoup les choses
et là justement on change beaucoup les
choses vous étiez là le 9 octobre
radiologie et vous aviez dit que vous
étiez prêt à être candidat à l'Élysée en
vous avez vous vous
comment dirais-je par un questionnement
destiné destiné à enfermer votre
interlocuteur dans une impasse
vous m'avez demandé si j'exclus ça non
j'ex
je ne changerai jamais vous n'excuse
rien
je n'arrive souvent de dire
je suis pas principalement en élu je
suis pas principalement président de
parti je suis pas principalement
responsable chargé d'une mission de
service public je suis pas
principalement à ma mère de d'une ville
géniale
je suis principalement est d'abord un
citoyen qu'est-ce que c'est un citoyen
c'est quelqu'un qui est engagé dans ce
qui se passe dans son temps
[Musique]
plus que vous savez cette cette devise
de la maison d'orange je maintiendrai je
maintiendrai je continuerai à porter ce
que je porte je continuerai à défendre
ce que je crois et si vous faites le
bilan des dernières années pardon de
dire ça comme ça vous trouverez un grand
nombre de sujets sur lesquels j'étais
seul j'en prends un la privatisation des
autoroutes
personne à l'époque majorité ou
opposition et dont on parle beaucoup
parce que c'était une erreur et je vois
des responsables beaucoup plus durs à
l'époque et je vois des responsables de
l'époque qui aujourd'hui disent on s'est
trompé peut-être ça aurait été mieux
d'écouter ce que
sur ce sujet là il y en a beaucoup
d'autres la dette personne n'acceptait
de parler de la dette lorsque en 2007
j'ai fait une campagne sur ce sujet
comme vous posez des questions laissez
je vous laisse répondre ça n'est pas ce
n'est pas une manière de de glorifier
l'action personnelle c'est de dire que
oui on peut arriver à discerner quand on
regarde attentivement les circonstances
les événements qui vont modifier la
situation d'un pays et les corriger
alors qu'il est temps parce qu'après il
n'est plus temps parce que en fait quand
on vous entend on se dit peut-être que
l'expérience d'un homme comme vous
François Béraud ça peut être un atout
pour la France et les Français dans
quatre ans j'espère bien que
l'expérience ça sert pas seulement la
mienne mais celle de tous ceux qui ont
eu l'occasion de bâtir ainsi un
patrimoine de de lucidité merci en tout
cas pour ça d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation bonne fin d'après-midi sur
radiologie il y a dimanche prochain
merci